monday the treasury department
sanctioned ethereum based tornado cache
for allegedly helping to launder more
than 7 billion worth of cryptocurrency
since its creation in 2019 effectively
freezing u.s assets on the platform and
barring americans from using the service
laundered funds included more than 455
million dollars stolen by north korean
hacking ring the lazarus group in the
largest known virtual currency heist to
date
the group stole roughly 620 million
dollars from ronin an ethereum linked
platform for the nft based video game
axi infinity in march these sanctions
are the latest retaliatory measures
against so-called virtual currency
mixing services which obfuscate
cryptocurrency transactions to make them
more difficult to track
on its website tornado cache says it's
helped more than 40 000 users obfuscate
transactions through more than 150 000
deposits that help achieve privacy by
using smart contracts to route funds to
an address with no ether balance and
then send it to a new public address
that has no link to the original sender
tornado cash was also used to launder
more than 96 million dollars of funds
derived from a june hack of blockchain
bridge harmony and at least 7.8 million
dollars from an attack on nomad which
lost about 190 million dollars in a
security exploit last week according to
the treasury
the move follows the treasury's first
ever sanctions on a virtual currency
mixer in may when it designated blender
dot io for allegedly helping process
20.5 million dollars worth of illicit
proceeds from the lazarus backed crypto
heist in march
in a post on its website monday crypto
policy think tank coin center criticized
the treasury's decision for quote
sanctioning a tool that is not an alias
of any person meriting sanction unquote
and said the move limits quote any
american who wishes to use her own money
and a freely available software tool to
maintain her own privacy including for
otherwise entirely legal and personal
reasons
[Music]
you